AINSLEY: THANKS SO MUCH, GRIFF.
LET’S BRING IN KAYLEIGH MCENANY,
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY,
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, KAYLEIGH.
>> GOOD MORNING, AINSLEY.
AINSLEY: WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION
YESTERDAY TO JOE BIDEN GOING
AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP ON THE
ECONOMY?
ACTUALLY, LET’S PLAY IT AND THEN
YOU CAN GET YOUR REACTION ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP KEEPS
TALKING ABOUT HOW GREAT THIS
ECONOMY IS, HOW GREAT THE
STOCK MARKET IS, IF IT
HADN’T BEEN SO GREAT FOR THE
REST OF US.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE OUT OF WORK,
EVICTIONS ON THE RISE,
20 MILLION PEOPLE WORRYING ABOUT
WHERE THEY’RE GOING TO LOSE
THEIR HOME, WHAT IN GOD’S NAME
ELSE CAN THIS GUY DO?
LET’S LOOK AT ONE SIMPLE FACT.
THIS PRESIDENT IS ON TRACK TO BE
THE ONLY PRESIDENT IN MODERN
HISTORY TO END UP WITH FEWER
JOBS AT THE END OF HIS TERM THAN
EXISTED IN AMERICA WHEN HE BEGAN
HIS TERM.
AINSLEY: KAYLEIGH IS THAT FAIR?
WE JUST WENT THROUGH, WE ARE IN
THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC.
>> YEAH, ONE THING FOR JOE, HE
WANTS TO TALK ABOUT SIMPLE FACTS
I HAVE A FEW SIMPLE FACTS FOR
HIM.
LET’S START WITH THE FACT THAT
OBAMA-BIDEN OVERSAW THE SLOWEST
ECONOMIC RECOVERY SINCE WORLD
WAR II.
HE HAD HIS BITE AT THE APPLE.
THAT’S WHAT THEY DELIVERED
COMPARE THAT TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
’S FASTEST ECONOMIC
RECOVERY IN MODERN HISTORY, THE
CBO TOLD US WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE DOUBLE-DIGIT
UNEMPLOYMENT UNTIL THE END OF
THE YEAR.
WE ARE IN SINGLE-DIGITS RIGHT
NOW, RECORD NUMBER OF JOBS
CREATED OUT PACING THE REST OF
THE WORLD IN TERMS OF AN
ECONOMIC RECOVERY, SO, WE’RE
ON TRACK WITH THE JOBS PRESIDENT
, BUT THE PATHETIC
RECORD OF OBAMA-BIDEN STANDS
VERY CLEAR, AND THOSE ARE SIMPLE
FACTS.
BRIAN:  THE OTHER THING THAT
EVERYONE IS TALKING ABOUT IS
EXCITED ABOUT BUT SEEMS TO BE
POLITICIZED IS THE RACE TO GET A
VACCINE THE PRESIDENT SAID
DECEMBER, HOPING FOR MAYBE
EARLIER IN NOVEMBER, JOE BIDEN
SAYS THE PRESIDENT HAS GOT A
CREDIBILITY ISSUE.
LET’S LISTEN.
>> I WOULD WANT TO SEE WHAT THE
SCIENTISTS SAID.
REPORTER: [INAUDIBLE] >> I WANT
FULL TRANSPARENCY ON A VACCINE.
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS IS THE WAY
HE’S PLAYING WITH POLITICS.
HE’S SAID SO MANY THINGS THAT
AREN’T TRUE I’M WORRIED IF WE DO
HAVE A REALLY GOOD VACCINE
PEOPLE WILL BE RELUCTANT TO TAKE
IT.
SO HE’S UNDERMINING PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE, BUT PRAY TO GOD WE
HAVE IT.
IF I COULD GET A VACCINE
TOMORROW I’D DO IT.
IF IT COST ME THE ELECTION I’D
DO IT.
WE NEED A VACCINE AND WE NEED IT
NOW.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> WE HAVE TO LISTEN TO THE
SCIENTISTS.
BRIAN:  WAS THE PRESIDENT GOING
TO COME UP WITH A VACCINE
HIMSELF OR  IS HE GOING TO
DEPEND ON THE SCIENTISTS?
>> HE’S GOING TO DEPEND ON THE
SCIENTIST WHICH IS IS WHAT
HE’S DONE EVERY SINGLE STEP OF
THE WAY.
WHAT YOU SEE DEMOCRATS DOING IS
VERY VERY DANGEROUS.
THEY ARE LITERALLY PLAYING
POLITICS WITH PEOPLE’S LIVES
HERE BY THROWING DOUBT ABOUT A
VACCINE.
WE HAVE EXPERTS OVER AT
OPERATION WARP SPEED THAT ARE
WORKING ON THIS , PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAS TORE THROUGH
BUREAUCRATIC BARRIERS SO WE CAN
GET A SAFE, EFFECTIVE, AND
TIMELY VACCINE, AND ONCE AGAIN,
COMPARE THAT TO OBAMA-BIDEN
WHERE THEY PROMISED A VACCINE,
THEY VASTLY UNDERPERFORMED AND
YOU HAVE BIDEN’S ADVISOR BACK IN
THE OBAMA-BIDEN DAYS SAYING IT’S
A PURE MIRACLE THAT SWINE FLU
WASN’T A MASS CASUALTY EVENT OF
OUR TIMES.
STEVE: YOU KNOW, KAYLEIGH LAST
TIME YOU WERE WITH US WE ASKED
YOU ABOUT THAT MUSIC.
YOU’D THINK THAT YOU BE ABLE TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE IT’S COMING
FROM.
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
APPARENTLY IT’S SOME SORT OF
PROTEST BUT WHAT’S FUNNY IS I
DON’T THINK THE VIEWERS CAN HEAR
THE MUSIC SO WE THINK WE’RE JUST
HEARING IT.
BRIAN:  NO WE COULD HEAR IT.
STEVE: HEY, YOU KNOW, CLEARLY,
THE PRESIDENT AS HE GOES TO
JUPITER, FLORIDA TODAY AND THEN
TO NORTH CAROLINA AS WELL, HE’S
GOING TO BE TALKING ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT TODAY DOWN IN
FLORIDA WHERE PEOPLE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE RED TIDE AND
BLUE ALGAE BUT ALSO TALKING
ABOUT THE CHAOS IN THE STREETS
AND THE ECONOMY.
NOW, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
HOGAN GIDLEY PUT OUT A STATEMENT
YESTERDAY TALKING ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT AND JOE BIDEN AND
ONE OF THE THINGS HE SAID WAS
THAT JOE BIDEN IS PROMISING TO
RAISE TAXES ON MORE THAN 80% OF
TAXPAYERS BY $4 TRILLION.
THAT’S A LOT OF MONEY ON SOCIAL
MEDIA, YOU SEE PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT HE’S GOING TO DOUBLE OUR
TAXES AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
WHERE ARE YOU GETTING THAT
FIGURE?
HE’S GOING TO RAISE $4 TRILLION
ON 80% OF THE PEOPLE.
>> YEAH, WELL JUST ONE SIMPLE
PROPOSAL LOOK AT THE PAYROLL TAX
ON CAPITOL HILL YOU HAVE A
DEMOCRAT THERE PROPOSING TO
ROLLBACK THE PRESIDENT’S PAYROLL
TAX FORGIVENESS.
THIS IS A HUGE TAX THAT FORGIVES
, THAT BENEFITS MOSTLY
MIDDLE AND LOW INCOME WORKERS
AND AT THE SAME TIME, WE’RE NOT
TOUCHING SOCIAL SECURITY BECAUSE
THE MONEY IS COMING OUT OF THE
GENERAL FUND TO PAY FOR THIS
, JUST SIMPLY THE
PAYROLL TAX, DEMOCRATS WILL
PULL THAT BACK AND ALSO THE
TRUMP TAX CUTS.
STEVE: BUT DOESN’T A MAJORITY OF
THE $4 TRILLION COME FROM PEOPLE
MAKING MORE THAN $400,000 A YEAR
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE TRUMP
TAX CUTS WHAT THEY’VE DONE IS
BENEFIT MOSTLY LOW AND MIDDLE
INCOME AMERICANS, AS A
PERCENTAGE, AND THE PAYROLL TAX
CUTS IN PARTICULAR, THAT’S FOR
PEOPLE MAKING UNDER $100,000
, AND IT IS A REGRESSIVE
TAX, AND WE KNOW THAT LOW AND
MIDDLE INCOME WORKERS THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THEIR TAXES COME
FROM THAT PAYROLL TAX, SO THAT’S
WHAT THIS PRESIDENT HAS
PRIORITIZED IN THE MIDST OF A
PANDEMIC AND YOU’LL HAVE JOE
BIDEN AND OTHERS ROLLING BACK
THOSE TRUMP TAX CUTS AND NOT
FORGIVING THE PAYROLL TAX WHICH
PRESIDENT TRUMP PROMISED HE
WOULD DO.
AINSLEY: KAYLEIGH THE SENATE IS
HEADING BACK TO WORK TODAY
WHAT’S THE LATEST ON THE COVID
RELIEF?
>> YEAH, RIGHT NOW AGAIN, IT’S
NANCY PELOSI PLAYING POLITICS.
SHE’S BEEN FUNDAMENTALLY UN
SERIOUS EVERY STEP OF THE WAY
HERE.
THEY WOULD ASK FOR A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF SCHOOL FUNDING WE
WOULD EXCEED THAT AMOUNT AND
THEN THEY WOULD REJECT IT.
SHE’S SAYING SHE WANTS
$2.5 TRILLION BUT WON’T SAY WHAT
THAT MONEY WILL GO TO.
DEMOCRATS WANT A BAILOUT FOR
BLUE STATES, AND
LOOK AT THE PRIORITIES HERE,
WHEN THIS PRESIDENT PUT OUT EO’S
TO HELP STOP EVICTIONS AND THAT
PAYROLL TAX CUT I MENTIONED, AND
OTHER ITEMS WHAT WAS NANCY
PELOSI DOING?
VACATIONING AND GOING TO A HAIR
SALON WHEN NO ONE ELSE IN
CALIFORNIA OR  IN HER AREA HAD
THE BENEFIT OF THAT.
BRIAN:  THE RUBBER HITS THE ROAD
EVIDENTLY IT’S MONEY TO STATES
AND WHO IT’S GOING TO GO TO AND
WHERE IT ENDOSCOPIES UP
MEANWHILE THE BIG STORY RESONAT
ING IS JEFFLY GOLDBERG’S
ATLANTIC MAGAZINE REPORT SAYS
THE PRESIDENT CALLED THOSE WHO
DIED IN WORLD WAR I SUCKERS AND
SOME OTHER DISPARAGING REMARKS
AND LOSERS AND VETERANS IN
PARTICULAR HE SAYS HE HAS
ANONYMOUS SOURCES AND MORE
COMING FORWARD AND WE DIDN’T
KNOW JOHN BOLTON TOLD MARTHA MCC
ALLUM LAST NIGHT WHOSE NOT A
FAN OF THE PRESIDENT THAT IT
DIDN’T HAPPEN THERE AND THE AID
TO GENERAL KELLY SAYS IT DIDN’T
HAPPEN AND HE WAS THERE.
WHO ELSE WAS THERE THAT YOU LIKE
TO HEAR FROM?
>> WELL I’VE HEARD FROM ENOUGH
PEOPLE.
I’VE HEARD IN FACT FROM 19 ON-
THE-RECORD SOURCES WHO PUT
THEIR NAMES ON THEIR TESTIMONY,
AND THOSE 19 SOURCES MORE THAN A
DOZEN OF WHICH HAVE FIRSTHAND
ACCOUNTS HAVE DISMISSED IT THAT
IT’S FUNDAMENTALLY UNTRUE.
YOU HAVE A LIBERAL ACTIVIST
PUBLICATION IN THE ATLANTIC WITH
THESE ABSOLUTE LIES ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND AGAIN,
ANONYMOUS COWARDLY ANONYMOUS
SOURCES WON’T PUT THEIR NAME ON
THEIR ALLEGATIONS BUT YOU HAVE
NOW ALMOST 20 PEOPLE PUTTING
THEIR NAMES ON THIS , AND SAYING
THIS IS FUNDAMENTALLY UNTRUE AND
THIS PRESIDENT LOVES OUR
VETERANS I SEE IT EACH AND EVERY
DAY.
HE DEEPLY CARES ABOUT OUR
MILITARY AND THIS IS DEMOCRATS
TRYING TO WEDGE VETERANS AWAY
FROM A PRESIDENT THAT HAS DONE